few quick questions for you in an Ideal
World how many Star Wars series a year
would you like to see on Disney plus
only the ones that are really good
but I'd be like do you like because I'm
not sure how it all comes like is it
were you thinking three series a year
four series a year you know we don't we
don't really think about it that way
because I'm not kidding when I say that
we talk about things in terms of story
and the people involved and arriving at
a place where we think it's going to be
great and that we should move forward so
even though we have a certain mandate
around a slate where we're being asked
to maybe do you know one or two a year
we wouldn't do that if we didn't feel we
were ready sure so that's the way we
look at it
um yesterday you guys announced three
features that are in development when do
you think is the soonest a new Star Wars
movie will be in the interesting way of
looking at it I've gotten a variety of
creative ways in which people have asked
me for release dates oh I actually but
like I actually don't want to know the
date I just like do you think 2025 is
realistic
stop it
I'll move on to a different question
there we go
um so with the movies that you guys
announced yesterday how much are you
thinking about these as Standalone films
and how much are you thinking about
these in the development process as an
upcoming what could be a Trilogy like
with Rey you know it's interesting that
you say that because we really are
looking at these as ways in which people
can enter Star Wars from different
places and not feel the burden of oh God
I gotta catch up with everything that's
been made before so we don't really talk
about it in terms of trilogies per se we
talk about it as stories obviously what
Ray is doing is a carryover of what
George created and what we carried on
with and what we're doing with the other
movies will be separate stories but they
will have a connection the connection is
really the overarching story of the Jedi
that's what we're looking at
um I asked oh uh you've obviously seen
Indiana Jones uh I I cannot wait for
this movie and for for some reason
stories about run time do very well for
us so I'm curious how long is Indiana
Jones
I'm being completely honest with you are
you kidding no these these stories these
they do really really well I swear to
you and Finn when fandom gets I'm not
lying to you this is a real thing so I
was curious all right so it's around two
hours and 20 to 23 minutes because run
time seems to be a Hot Topic then I will
say that the early movies were shorter
they were under 215 but I think we and
we talked about that quite a bit so now
I see why maybe they're interested in
this but as you know with runtime it's
all about how you feel right so if
you're sitting in a movie and it feels
long you're like yeah 220 is not a long
movie no no like no it's no we're not
dealing with a long movie yeah by the
way like I love the Batman Batman's
three hours I could watch a four hour
version of that movie yeah no and I you
know what I think I think is the reason
this is interesting is because long form
storytelling is becoming something that
we like in the streaming space right
exactly so I think it might be that it
it's some kind of carryover from that
but God knows I have to say this year
there were so many three-hour Plus
movies that I felt like I wasn't getting
any work done trying to see them some of
those three-hour movies need to be
shorter yes and some of them some are
fine and some like the Batman is an
example well let's give people like
David lean and Stanley Cooper Credit you
know they did that too so if it's good
and it's high quality then bring it on